How does the SBI pro-dietary supplement work to assist in molecular non-hudge insulin phoma just
be good using that? So, the SBI pro-sumpliment is a little globulant. So, there's a lot of different
immunoglobulin supplements out there that can be really helpful for the gut. So, immunoglobulins
take it as a supplement to help decrease the inflammation in the gut. So, they kind of act like
like a sponge to grab on the stuff in the gut to get it out of the gut. So, it decreases inflammation
in the gut. And remember, when you have inflammation systemically, whether it's inflammation in the
brain or its inflammation in the tissues, will we decrease inflammation in the gut? We're
going to decrease systemic inflammation. So, the purpose of doing, so how's the lymphoma? Why would
you take, you know, to work on gut inflammation if I have lymphoma? Well, working on gut inflammation
can help systemic inflammation. So, it can help any disorder. Speaking of Parkinson's,
working on it, I mentioned one of the major components of Parkinson's is trying to find sources
of inflammation in the brain. And I mentioned dietary things like getting rid of gluten and dairy
and things like that in your diet. And people might go, what is he talking about, dealing with gluten?
I have Parkinson's. How does that relate? Well, you have inflammatory processes that go out of the
gut are going to cause inflammation systemically. So, anytime you can decrease inflammation that
got, you're going to decrease inflammation systemically. So, that would be the mechanism of action